je prendrais bien une petite tartine de
tapenade parmi les matières produites
par votre corps auquel vous n'avez
probablement pas du tout envie d'être
confronté et vomissements fécaloïdes
vomissements comme vomir et fait
calloïdes comme
vous voyez comme ça attention avoir des
vomissements fécaloïdes ça ne veut pas
dire vomir du caca au sens strict disons
que les vomissements apprennent l'aspect
et l'odeur des matières fécales
bon déjà rien que ça c'est pas très
convivial enfin en réalité c'est plutôt
du liquide des sécrétions intestinales
chargées de toute la petite armée de
bactéries fécales qui remonte ce mélange
au contenu de l'estomac avant de
ressortir par le haut et si ça sort par
en haut c'est parce que c'est bouché par
en bas ça peut aussi mais c'est
rarissime être le signe d'une fistule
gastrocholique alors une fistule c'est
une espèce de canal qui se crée entre
deux organes qui devraient pas
communiquer entre normalement donc là en
l'occurrence une fistule gastrocolique
c'est une fistule entre l'estomac et le
gros intestin dans tous les cas vous
vous en doutez c'est grave hein donc la
solution c'est la chir